I want to start today by talking about
how lying became acceptable in American
politics you know we've talked about
George Santos over the last several
weeks we've seen the lives of so many
Republicans in the context of the house
Speaker Fiasco and it's just liars and
liars and liars and of course we saw
four years of Donald Trump and the
amount of dishonesty that was that was
there it is unfortunately true that
lying has become acceptable in the sense
that it does not significantly damage a
politician or candidate's chances of
winning elected office while it's
generally understood like oh lying is
bad in some cultural sense we still sort
of look down at lying
politicians regularly lie or mislead the
public without really suffering
significant consequences and in fact in
some cases politicians have been able to
win elections after being caught in
really really bad lies how did this come
to be
one reason for this is that it's become
easier for politicians to get away with
lying because of the proliferation of
news sources and the spread of
misinformation on social media it can
actually be tougher
for the average person who's busy
working to sort through all of the
information and determine what's true
and what is not true which means that
politicians can make false statements
and have them spread quickly even if
they're later debunked and often avoid
any consequences
the political climate is increasingly
divisive and partisan and politicians
might feel pressure to lie in order to
win or to advance their agendas they may
feel that the ends justify the means and
that lying is a necessary part of the
game and it seems as though many voters
agree with that that same partisanship
and polarization I've talked about it
before is you know we we see ourselves
as fighting a war here and even if the
Battle Is Lost in the sense that we made
stuff up it's for the greater good of
winning this war and so when you have
the politicians really willing to do it
and the voters unwilling to punish for
it you get what is essentially
acceptable lying
it's important for citizens to hold
politicians accountable for the things
they say and the things they do and to
demand transparency and honesty and it
would be really difficult to completely
eliminate lying in politics but we have
a situation right now where voters are
as welcoming as ever of Lies if they
further what those voters already
believe should be what our elected
officials are doing uh many examples of
like pretty big lies in history and we
can talk about some of them uh George
H.W bush remember the whole read my lips
no new taxes thing during his 88
presidential campaign he famously
promised not going to raise taxes in
office he signed a budget deal that
included tax increases his broken
promise was criticized uh but uh we
could say
the damage wasn't massive even though he
did lose right ultimately he did lose in
1992 to Bill Clinton Bill Clinton then
said I did not have sexual relations
with that woman he did it was just a
straight up lie and although it did lead
to what we know the investigation the
impeachment all this different stuff
um his approval rating really didn't
suffer and ultimately he got himself
reelected so another example and again
I'm not passing value judgments on these
these are just examples of lying
essentially being acceptable Barack
Obama not everything Obama said worked
out to be true and Barack Obama said if
you like your health care plan you can
keep it this was during the debate
around the Affordable Care Act known as
Obamacare let's assume he meant it at
the time or he wanted it to be true
there are people who lost their health
care plans even though they like them
because the new law made them uh invalid
or non-compliant I think would be the
way to say it and there was controversy
around it Republicans talked about it
Barack Obama was re-elected in 2012. now
there were so many other things going on
we can't simply say he lied about that
and then got reelected it's more
complicated than that but we're building
up this picture and then with Trump it's
quite literally thousands thousands
thousands of Lies some big some small
just to pick a few different things
Trump's claims about voter fraud in 2016
he said he actually won the popular vote
he didn't in 2020 he said he won the
election he didn't major lie absolutely
huge lie his supporters just bought it
they they believe it they aren't they
didn't punish him for those obvious lies
Trump's obvious lies about the size of
of the inauguration crowd Trump's claims
about coronavirus 15 cases will be zero
and you know inject bleach all this
different stuff
lies dishonesty Etc
so at the end of the day
it's important for citizens to hold
politicians accountable for their words
and for their actions and part of that
has to be that it has to be unacceptable
to the voters to have the level of lying
and dishonesty that we have seen
particularly from more recent Leaders
The Missing Link is as follows voters
are more willing to overlook or excuse
lies in dishonesty
when politicians from their party are
the ones telling the lies and this can
happen out of a sense of loyalty out of
a sense of well the other side is way
way way worse and in the highly partisan
political climate that we have voters
are already tending to seek out
information that supports their
pre-existing beliefs this is called
confirmation bias that leads to the
spread of misinformation and it leads to
the acceptance or at minimum at minimum
the indifference to misleading
statements over lies as long as they
align with your political views I try
not to fall for this and if I see
something that the left is saying that
doesn't make sense I don't go with it
you know I know there's lots of people
on the left who still say GMO food is
bad just by virtue of being GMO I don't
see the facts backing that up I don't
see the studies and the science backing
that up so I don't repeat it regardless
of who it is that's on one side or the
other side of the issue it's a minor
example but it's an example
we should all be striving to do that and
until that changes lying will continue
to be a viable strategy in American
politics what ultimately happens with
George Santos where it's so extreme and
cartoonish we don't know we will see
Donald Trump gave an interview so
delusional that even the very friendly
host Darren Beatty was not able to save
him this is really something else and
Trump as we know has barely left his
house since announcing that he was
running for president for the 2024
Republican nomination he is increasingly
beaten down and defeated morally
and increasingly a laughing stock
doesn't mean he won't be the nominee
doesn't mean that but it's getting even
more pathetic than it has been he was
interviewed on Revolver news by Darren
Beatty and he says he's reading
Twitter's only shot at survival is if he
goes back on and abandons his existing
platform truth Central listen to this
there are those that are saying that
Twitter can never be Twitter unless I go
back on I'm very complimented by that
and I only say it because there are
about 20 articles about it right but
Twitter can never make it if they don't
have Trump back on and if you look at
the truths that I put out today and
somebody put out some truths or truths
you're going to be put out momentarily I
think you'll see that you know the
number one they're correct number two
they're good for the country and they
are
pretty well crafted I must say those
truths are nicely crafted but I hope
you're going to look at the ones that I
just put out and did you see the ones I
put out today there
yes yes
no they're very good and um we'll we'll
get it yeah they're just really really
good truths I mean the host sounds like
he realizes how cringy it is to have to
tell Trump his truths are good but then
it gets even worse where Darren Beatty
starts sucking up to Trump saying oh sir
you're the only guy to keep us out of a
war and it just gets worse and worse and
worse you're one of the only presidents
in a long time not to bring us into any
new Wars and that's something people
really need to appreciate especially
given all of Biden's sailings in the
foreign policy stage well Putin would
have never gone into Ukraine 100 I used
to talk to him about there's zero chance
uh she would never have even thought
about Taiwan uh which he is thinking
about seriously he wouldn't have ever
thought about it the Afghanistan removal
was so bad that it gave them additional
momentum that would have never happened
I would have I was the one that got our
soldiers way down but I would have kept
Bagram definitely because because of
China you know an hour away from China
plants
where they make their nuclear weapons so
I would have I would have done that but
but uh you know we would have had the
soldiers take it out last not take it
out first in Afghanistan so you know all
those things the big mistakes that were
made were so bad you know this idea that
Trump's the only guy and who knows how
long to keep us out of new Wars or
whatever you know the the truth is uh
Jimmy Carter uh Gerald Ford Nixon they
all served uh more recently than is
often pointed to Eisenhower and didn't
bring the country into new Wars now of
course a lot of this is in the you know
the devil is in the details are we
talking about an authorization
authorization for military force are we
talking about bombing are we talking
about droning Trump did plenty of
droning and the the phraseology of new
Wars is so tired but he continues
repeating it and it's just it's bogus
and and even on the Nationals here I
think when Putin looked at that disaster
in Afghanistan he said this is my time
to do it but you know I was the only one
in four or five presidents where Russia
didn't take over land
and again even that's not really true uh
because Russia did consolidate
um its presence in the Donetsk and the
luhansk and to say take over I mean
listen they didn't announce an
annexation until Biden was president but
they were there every single one of
these claims is meaningless
and even this friendliest of friendly
hosts
can't make Trump look like he has any
clue what he is talking about join me to
uh Wednesday January 11th 6 PM for the
next David Pacman show Town Hall it'll
be live streaming and you can
participate on our Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord that'll be 6 PM
East 3 P.M West on Wednesday January
11th
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show in 2023 continues
to be an audience supported program you
can sign up and support the work that we
do all of us at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a discount whether you need it
or not we don't means test the discounts
take it if you want it and uh you also
of course are more than welcome to sign
up on any of the other platforms on
which we allow that all right let's talk
to people from the audience we do this
via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord we have
um so many people waiting to chat so
let's not delay any further let's really
get right into it why don't we first
talk to and again this is just first
let's talk to Drew from New York Drew
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
wait can you hear me yes I can
wonderful it's great to be here it's my
first time on call Great what's going on
today
so um first question given that right
now they're doing I think the fourth
ballot for the house if I um why do you
think the over under is for 12 ballots
yeah honestly I have no idea and by the
time this airs we'll almost certainly
know what the outcome was so I don't
even want to wade into that
that's fair it's fair
um they like the questions I've had I've
been holding on for since the midterms
but so I don't know I don't I hope you
don't mind if I ask about not at all
so or in your opinion what do you think
was the the biggest up single upset for
any of any of the individual elections
from the midterms oh you know what my
memory goes blank like five days after
any event until I review the biggest
upset uh well I mean in a sense it was
even though she still won the narrow
margin that Lauren bobert ended up going
by like it wasn't an upset and that she
still came away a winner but it was such
a slim margin so I I mean I think that
that was very interesting there were a
number of races where the margin was was
much smaller for the Republican than
expected and it just all kind of goes to
is Maga deflating and we'll we'll know
probably pretty soon if the answer is
yes
that makes them make sense I I had
always had it in mind that for me that
it was the Wisconsin governor not just
the fact that Evers is able to win but
by the margin that he was able to yeah
that's that's a good one that that may
be it yeah I would have to review uh you
you caught me off guard but there were a
number of them Drew right and the last
one this should be quick given with the
last
um midterm election being decided with
the runoff would you rather be a vampire
or a werewolf well I think I would
rather be a werewolf because the idea of
drinking blood is very unappealing to me
that's true yeah that would that
wouldn't work for me I don't think
all right all right my friend thank you
for the call
thank you all right there goes Drew with
a number of questions we always love to
see that let's go uh why don't we go
next to yoel or yoel from Ontario Canada
our friendly neighbors to the north
what's going on is it yoel
can you hear me yeah I can hear you fine
my question is um do you think it's
possible to be an ethical consumer in
today's globalized society
yeah you know I've gotten you it wasn't
you who called with this exact same
question like a month ago right
no it was okay yeah so okay here's
here's the thing let's assume the answer
is no you can't be an ethical consumer
in this Society then then what do we do
what's what do we do based on that if
that were the answer just indulge me for
a moment let's say I said you know
you'll you all it you can't be an
ethical consumer right now nope what
what would what would you do
are you asking me personally yeah
um I guess you have to just kind of do
the best you can
um
that's why I'm asking you really is
because like for example the World Cup
was on recently yep and initially I was
going to boycott it out of obviously the
human rights violations of Migrant
workers dying or whatnot but then I
realized by hypocrisy was for example
if I go to England or Germany or
whatever those World Cups and those
leagues still sponsor I take sponsors
from Nike and Adidas and other companies
that still exploit workers and in China
and in Bangladesh and whatnot right so
it almost seems like no matter what I do
I'm in I'm in a I'm just being a
hypocrite you know I'm just yeah and
choosing what I think is personally
important to me I know exactly what
you're saying this is the difficulty and
we've we need to find the balance
between
living completely off the grid and
isolating yourself from all of these
things which almost none of us are
willing to do I mean almost literally no
one is willing to do that or doing the
best we can to both make decisions we
feel okay it doesn't we don't have to
feel great but we feel like we can
accept the decisions we're making
and where we think things are not right
doing what we can as activists to affect
change so at the end of the day I mean
you make a good point I covered for a
decade leading up to the Qatar World Cup
there was corruption in how Qatar got
the World Cup horrible treatment of what
are essentially slaves building the
stadiums deaths and cover-up of the
deaths promises made by the qataris
about kosher food and LGBT people and
all these things that they went back all
this different stuff and I covered it
all along and then we get to the games
at this point the cake is baked and I
want to see Argentina you know I was
born in Argentina I want to see if
Argentina wins and and and Argentina won
and it was a you know great thing
um where where is the balance do I feel
okay enough with the fact that after a
decade of talking about how horrible it
was I watched a couple games you know I
do I'm okay with it in the grand scheme
of my life and everybody has to kind of
decide for themselves
yeah I kind of feel like in a sense it's
almost too much for an individual to
take the burden trying to boycott every
little thing I kind of think it relies
more someone is turning to International
organizations to kind of
um place better restrictions on where
you know for example like
a lot of cobalt comes from slave Minds
in the Congo I think it's too much of a
burden for me to boycott all
rechargeable batteries because it's just
not a good life to live right
um I think it relies more so on the UN
and international bodies to sort of act
in our favor try and
um orchestrate some way where it's
reasonable for me to be an ethical
consumer it's not on me to just sort of
boycott every little thing because that
would just make my life miserable I
agree with that I also think that as
activists and voters we need to demand
of those organizations that they
actually do the things you're talking
about you know so so there's really an
element of all these things but I I
think you're thinking about this roughly
the way I am
right yeah just because I've just it
made me feel bad kind of initially
watching the World Cup but then I just
realized that like it's just too much of
a burden for one person to put on their
shoulders to try and boycott every
little thing that's wrong about the
world right especially such a globalized
economy and that doesn't mean we give up
and it doesn't mean we don't care yeah I
appreciate the call Yol thank you thank
you all right there's Joel from Ontario
great to hear uh from him very very
exciting stuff let's go to Stoney from
Indiana Stoney from Indiana welcome to
the program uh what's on your mind today
yeah
yeah hey David uh can you hear me yes I
can Stoney welcome
awesome thank you
um yeah so I had a question obviously uh
either whether you're Republican or
Democrat everyone knows funding is how
our system runs
um I find it interesting in a state like
Indiana for example uh with the
overturning of Roe v wave there's no
real way to support that other than
donating to
a certain non-profit organizations but
for example there's fundraising through
like license plates so there's you know
Riley's Children's Hospitals they even
have one for Tony Stewart who's you know
a murderer as we all know
um but there's nothing for abortion so
do you know why that is or how you can
change that I don't so just so I
understand Stoney you're talking about
how in some states there's these like
pro-life license plates where when you
choose it it's like I remember up in
Massachusetts you could get one that was
like Cape Cod and the islands and a
little money went to conservation or you
could get one that was whatever else
you're saying that there there are
states where you're basically a portion
of your vanity plate goes to an
anti-abortion charity but you've never
seen one that goes to a pro-choice
organization uh exactly I haven't either
and I don't know the answer to I don't
know why I genuinely have no idea why
I I've seen uh there that I've done a
bit of research on it but it's a bit
convoluted there's uh around 14 States
or so that offer something around that
range that offers some sort of pro-life
sort of plate
um I I believe I I mean I'm not a lawyer
but from what I've read if you have like
a non-profit organization they can
submit and have it approved and it
started of course in Florida with uh uh
Jeb Bush sued and got it overturned it's
it's got an interesting history but from
what I've been able to gather the only
states that you can really find this in
are obviously like California and Oregon
and places like that
um but in you know the Midwest for
example you can't you can find religious
vanity plates you can we have you know
60 different available options to us
even the Boy Scouts Girl Scouts Etc uh
but there's nothing for us everyday
people to a support pro-life and B uh be
able to I think you mean the support
pro-choice right you mentioned
pro-choice yes yes correct correct yeah
I mean listen if it's as you describe
then it sounds like it requires the
activism of submitting and then getting
enough votes to make that an option in
States it could I don't know enough
about it but if that's the case it's a
question of getting an activist campaign
going to demand it
yes I agree I think it's just one simple
way we can give back
um for that so yeah thank you very much
David all right Stoney from Indiana
thank you very much for the call I
appreciate that why don't we go next
just I mean listen we're taking calls
we're all here we're connected let's
just talk to a few other people let's go
to Elon from New York Elon from New York
welcome to the program what's going on
can you hear me yes I can
okay uh you recently talked about incorp
about including nuclear energy as a way
to combat climate change and as more
interest in nuclear energy starts to
grow do you think that maybe we should
start considering thorium as an energy
source have you heard of thorium I've
heard about it I don't know enough about
it to be able to really say you know we
did an interview about
um you know fission and fusion and the
advancement there and we've talked about
new nuclear as a bridge to totally
renewable uh green energy Etc I I just
don't know enough about Thorium to
intelligently weigh in on it
oh can I give you some examples as what
I've heard just they may convince you
yeah I mean so are you actually
knowledgeable enough but you're not just
spitballing here you actually know about
it
I did some research on it I'm I'm a
physics major and I studied um
some did some read some articles on
Dorian okay tell me what it is explain
to me in the simplest terms this is a
real test of whether one understands
something whether you can explain it in
really simple terms
Auditorium is uh as oh I was going to
say territorium on the periodic table is
atomic number is number 90. it's three
times more available to the planet than
uranium it's easier to mine it has
higher concentrations in its word than
uranium
and one of the things that scientists
are saying that
it's the science of study says is that
it's that's well that with plutonium it
can produce up to 30 times more energy
than uranium okay and which is up to two
times more which is two point mil by one
ton of thorium can produce up to 2.5
million
and one tonatorium is equal to Great
enough energy equivalent to 2.5 million
tons of coal and it's much more cleaner
and efficient than
um than um
a Coleman industry I'm sorry from
spitballing but that's what I'm coming
from from my brain okay well listen I
mean it sounds interesting I don't know
that right now I'm going to learn enough
about it to be able to weigh in but let
me research it
okay it's just an interesting topic and
I feel that with nuclear energy being
more acceptable particularly I'm not
sure how much the left accepted I think
we should consider all our options
instead of just I know we're a fan of
renewable energy but I think we should
consider all our options and regarding a
serious issue like climate change we
should always consider all of our
options that I'm with you
okay uh and also a quick question
um now that
um now that we're heading into the 224
um election season
do you think
what other methods what main methods do
you think the left needs to improve on
in terms of marketing they're
ensure that whatever candidates or
whatever their agenda is for the
upcoming elections so before you can get
to tactics before we even get the
tactics the left has to dramatically
improve its messaging and decide on
exactly what the platform and the and
the sales pitch essentially is going to
be the left is a little bit all over the
place on that before we even talk about
marketing tactics they got they got to
figure that out all right my friend I
appreciate the call thank you so much
I thank you have a good day all right a
lot of things on people's minds today
very very much things on people's minds
which is important why don't we go next
to Simon from Montana Simon welcome to
the program uh what's going on in
Montana can you hear me yes I can
oh that's awesome uh a long time viewer
I really love your show and I look
forward to it every day well I
appreciate that what what's it like
living in Montana I have a friend who's
a doctor who does medicine seasonally in
Montana and finds it a very very
interesting place
oh um that's that's awesome uh do you
know what town he lives in well I don't
want to say
oh yeah because it's so rural there that
there might only be 10 people in that
town and everyone will know who I'm
talking about you know
yeah yes absolutely well it's very cold
right now
um and yeah a lot of a lot of red I live
in sort of a blue bubble in
um one of the two blue bubbles I will
say so you don't have like a 45 minute
drive to get groceries or anything like
that
no it's it's pretty good here for sure
it's all right if you want to go to like
Europe do you have to what you fly to
like Chicago and then Chicago to Europe
or is it more complicated than that
um well our airport goes I would say
generally we take our airport to yeah
somewhere like I guess Spokane or
something like that is generally where
I've been going huh but from Spokane I
can't imagine you're getting to London
for example right oh no
um well I've only been to Mexico out of
the country I believe we went somewhere
near Spokane fair and then yeah well
what's I've had so many questions it
seems only fair to allow you to ask one
well thank you I appreciate them
um and I I was just I've been wondering
for the last couple weeks I know you've
talked about the migrant bussing stunts
that are absolutely disgusting and
horrible deplorable
um and I just wanted to know obviously
these people like Greg Abbott and
DeSantis are doing it because they feel
like it scores them political points
with their base right um otherwise they
wouldn't continue to do it I was
wondering like
as the left as a media sphere what can
we do to prevent us to stop that or or I
think we should be aiming resources at
preventing this from being something
that scores them political points
because obviously so horrifying if it
doesn't score them political points so
so here's the issue if it does score
them political points I don't know that
the left can do much about that because
it's working and their constituents like
it I do think being on the same page
about explaining why it's deplorable and
disgusting makes sense so that hopefully
people who hear about it that might say
oh that's interesting that proves a
point then they hear oh actually here's
why it's crazy and it's financially a
disaster and it's immoral and it's
unethical and it's treating people like
objects and and pawns Etc but what
really we need is an electorate where it
wouldn't score the many points so it's a
much broader change that needs to be
affected
yeah yeah it's definitely a bit of a
wicked issue there and um yeah so well
yeah that was pretty much all that's on
my mind and it really is like I'm a big
strong guy but with tears in my eyes it
is an honor to talk to you so and just
last thing can you get a good bagel in
Montana
oh God no sir okay thank you very much
well now I'm the one who has tears in
his eyes thanks thanks for the call
Simon I appreciate it of course all
right we're gonna take the quickest of
breaks if you're still holding we're
going right back to the phones so I
would I would suggest that you stay with
me here very quick break and then we
will be right back and hear from more of
you
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more folks in the audience
for the first time in 2023 we take calls
via Discord at davidpackman.com Discord
you can join the waiting Lobby if you
want to talk to me you can raise your
hand almost like fifth grade all over
again which is exciting let's go to
melody in Missouri melody in Missouri
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today and thank you for being a
website member by the way I very much
appreciate that
all right Melody may be gone that's too
bad
I was looking forward to speaking with
Melody let's instead go to JWR from
Atlanta Georgia JWR welcome I know you
won't let us down
no of course not
um happy to um
um
um I'm I'm happy that you were that you
were able to work happy to be here um I
hope hope you're enjoying your new year
um sorry if I seem good for that kid I'm
just kind of um watching all the chaos
unfold as they as see I'm uh as McCarthy
as McCarthy um uh like I think it was
Einstein who said that who defined
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting a different
results and Republicans have certainly
been doing that this week
yes okay so regardless of how this turns
out what do you think
um I regardless of how this turns out
what do you think is like I guess I
guess house Democrats best chance of
like using the chaos that is inevitably
going to unfold in their in their in in
their in their favor when it comes to
the next election cycle Here's my
thought okay
uh Republicans are going to try to
obstruct Democrats from getting anything
done and then in 2024 they're going to
say don't vote for these Democrats they
didn't get anything done the opportunity
for Democrats here given that Democrats
will control the Senate do not control
the house but it's very close in the
house is there should be situations
where it's either going to be uh some
kind of spending bill made up mostly of
Common Sense stuff that all Americans
want or we might get a debt ceiling
situation or we are going to have things
come up in the next couple of years
where Democrats in the House and Senate
are going to be United with the American
people in the Senate that will be one
situation because Democrats control it
what's going on
sorry are you talking to someone else or
to me
oh no it's background noise oh geez okay
uh I so the point I'm trying to make is
democrats should have some opportunities
to really make Republicans look very
stupid and unnecessarily obstructionist
in opposition to some bills that the
entire American public will mostly be in
favor of Democrats have to just be
prepared to take advantage of those
opportunities to be able to fight back
in 24 against the narrative that
Democrats got nothing done thanks to
Republicans Force Republicans to either
give you some wins or really make
themselves look like they don't have the
interests of the American people uh uh
in mind if they do get in the way of
every single thing Democrats try to do I
think that's the one and only
opportunity
yes and I would also like to add like
while not giving them any time to eat
like any easy or obvious wins that could
that that could um
just as long as we don't do the thing
where it's where we somehow managed to
snatch the defeat from the jaws of
Victory which is not completely which is
not as important which is not impossible
that's absolutely absolutely the case
JWR thank you for the call I appreciate
it
of course always happy to be here
JWR from Atlanta Georgia Wow Let's go to
Micah from Idaho Micah from Idaho not a
heavily represented State among live
callers welcome Micah
hello thank you uh so I had two quick
questions if that's okay but first I
wanted to see how your New Years was did
you do anything fun or I had uh I had
dinner with some friends and uh my baby
daughter completely lost it and
um that was basically it yeah
oh dang
well
but the good news was the following was
another kid
sneezed directly into my daughter's face
and my daughter didn't get sick so I
consider that a win
that is a win my dog sneeze on my face
basically every morning it's it's
fantastic your dogs highly recommend yes
can humans get like stuff from dogs they
can't right
um
like covid
um there are a couple of like parasites
that they can carry that dogs or that
humans can get to but for the most part
like parvo and like the things that they
typically deal with are more
specifically dogs all right well good
not good for the dogs good for the
humans I guess
sure but what's on your mind um
well I was gonna see so um
you had a caller mentioned the uh the
stunts with uh sending the migrants to
to different places where they're not
going like Kamala Harris's house yeah
Kamala Kamala
Kamala okay
I was just wondering so like I don't
really
see any political gain for anyone in
that situation like I have a hard time
seeing like what the right wing would
see as desirable
in that could you help me like
understand what's going on there like
wow so here's what they need to
understand to understand why Republicans
think that that's a good idea okay
Republicans have this ideology I guess
we would call it which we sometimes call
strict father morality which means that
people should suffer the consequences of
their actions if you have uh sexual
relations outside of marriage you should
have to suffer the consequences of
getting pregnant and carrying the child
to term you can't get a get out of jail
free card like birth control or the
morning after pill or an abortion right
even if those are solutions that there's
no real reason to to prevent being
available to people and similarly
Republicans believe and Micah you have
to get into the mind of the Republican
Republicans believe that it is Democrats
and not Republicans Democrats in blue
states that are saying open the Border
let everybody in no control at all right
even though Democrats aren't saying
these things this is the story
Republicans tell themselves so
Republicans believe if Democrats in blue
states are going to be the one letting
everybody in the immigrants should be
sent to the blue states to make those
blue States deal with the consequences
of letting everybody in it's all made up
Micah don't get me wrong but that's the
internal logic that they apply to it
that's why they think it's a great thing
to send the migrants to Martha's
Vineyard and DC from Texas and Florida
okay thank you that makes a little more
sense yeah I mean it makes no sense but
hopefully what they are thinking now you
understand which is insane
yes that is correct yeah all right all
right Micah thank you appreciate the
call
uh okay thanks all right there is Micah
from Idaho
with uh with a great question quite
frankly let's go to Louis from New
Brunswick Louis from New Brunswick
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
Louis from New Brunswick I see that
you've muted yourself if you unmute
yourself we'll be able to talk so sorry
that was uh that was my mistake there
you go um thanks for having me David
great great to be here love your show
pleasure
um about a month ago about 20 retired
intelligence professionals penned a
letter to the Wall Street Journal
stating that in their opinion the hunter
Biden lifetime story bore all the
Hallmark signs of a Russian uh psyop
operation
yeah and in fact I believe it was 51.
did how what number did you say 20. I'm
reading that it was 51 former Intel
officials oh okay yeah you're right I
was just guessing uh based on my uh you
know full of memory but you're right 51.
and then um then I remember you covered
the story a while ago of this strange
origin story of how Madison Catherine
got married yeah you know some Russian
woman came over to the U.S and like a
fake uh uh fitness competition
yeah
my question to you Dave is do you think
that Russian intelligence services are
much more uh ingrained in our society
that we uh that that we like accept or
consider so I think Russian intelligence
is much more infiltrated in the United
States than the average person is aware
of I think our intelligence agencies
know the degree to which it's the case
but yeah I think that there are all
sorts of ways in which the average
American isn't aware but it's not just
Russia I think it's important to mention
there's lots of countries whose
intelligence services are very ingrained
and very slick but Russia is certainly
one of them
in your opinion do you think it's
possible that uh the Donald the
political Donald Trump that we are aware
of in the current sense is in fact a
product of this sort of infiltration no
I don't have any evidence for that I
think you know we have to be really
careful because next thing you know the
right Wingers will be saying oh you you
thought there was going to be video of
trump and Putin planning stuff I think
Trump is sort of a useful idiot for a
lot of different movements and people
and it's very clear from what we know
that Russian intelligence took an
interest in Trump decades ago to some
degree as they take an interest in many
American Business people it's not unique
to Trump but over time they clearly
realize Trump is kind of a doofus and
his ego and his narcissism maybe make
him a more interesting Ally in some
sense and at the end of the day we know
Russia had a preference for Trump over
Hillary in 2016 doesn't mean Trump's an
agent or a spy or anything like that
he's just kind of a useful idiot that's
the reality
okay I guess that's comforting in a
sense to hear yeah I mean we don't have
to go more conspiratorial than the facts
point to but to say there's nothing
there I mean listen he was doing he was
being invited to Russia decades ago
Russia was casually cultivating him at
the way they do many uh and they had a
preference for Trump over Hillary that
we can say with certainty
okay got an economic question for you if
you have time sure
so I got into a lively conversation with
a couple buddies at work some uh they're
you know all over the political spectrum
and I was I was wondering if you feel
like uh Social Security is a socialistic
program as opposed to you know looking
at the Spectrum the political Spectrum
economic spectrum as opposed to like a
fascistic uh policy okay and I was
here's the issue with these terms all
right okay in some very general sense
any time you collect money
for a program through taxation and then
distribute the money
in some narrowly defined way you can
argue it is in a sense socialistic in
practice what we're talking about here
are capitalist economies with social
welfare programs where the vast majority
of the money you make at most incomes
you get to keep
some slice of it goes to programs and
there is some redistribution there there
is certainly there are certainly folks
who get more than they put in and vice
versa that doesn't mean that it is a
socialist country or economy we might
just be saying there are certain areas
where we want to use the collective good
for the betterment of society and it
becomes almost semantic when people say
is it socialistic well maybe what do you
mean by that but these are programs that
every social democracy which are
capitalist countries have and it makes
what what we call it kind of irrelevant
interesting well yeah because I felt
like I feel like in a universal a
universal human uh uh response of
disgust is towards
um hypocrisy it doesn't matter like what
religion what Creed you know everybody
is usually offended by hypocrisy yeah so
if this person was uh saying like it's
very very right on the on the Spectrum
and was looking forward to receiving
Social Security and I was like well it's
funny because that you're so excited
about that because I consider something
like that and also unemployment
insurance
socialistic policies yeah I don't think
they're socialistic I think they're just
social safety nets that come that are
put in place in capitalist societies and
by the way I mean you pay into Social
Security so it makes sense that you
should get money out in that in that
sense that's nothing like socialism
by their definition so the these
semantic discussions in my mind really
miss the point Louis
interesting David it's been a pleasure
talking to you today the pleasure has
been all on this side of the microphone
Louis thank you
all right there goes Louie thank you to
everyone that called in that does it for
today we will take a break and we will
take calls again if I have anything to
say about it
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's do the Friday mail bag
you can email info davidpackman.com
kicking off 2023. it's a very full
mailbag
um you also sometimes will see a YouTube
comment here or there or a Facebook
message that we get or whatever the case
may be it's a mix of commentary and we
are going to start with a message from
Bruce delivered via the Facebook where
Bruce says you a real Punk clown you
make average American sick lying that's
that's not American that's American sick
lying good liberal girl whatever your
pronoun is f you
and then after being told I'm unable to
respond to comments individually
Bruce writes back not sure why this POS
lying liberal clown Dave packman garbage
popped up on my Facebook but can
guarantee I can't stand feckless lying
liberal cowards like him relay the
message to Dave he speaks for maybe 29
percent of Arizona at most
effin Punk clown
uh that's extremely specific I speak for
29 of Arizona I didn't claim to speak
for any of Arizona but apparently this
guy says it's conceivable that I speak
for 29 of Arizona so this is a very
angry person
who seems totally disconnected from the
reality in his state which is more
people voted for Katie Hobbs Katie Hobbs
defeated Kerry Lake Katie Hobbs is now
thankfully the governor of Arizona there
aren't two Governors the governor's not
Kerry Lake Carrie Lakes not the
governor-elect Kerry lake is not going
to use a lawsuit to become the governor
Katie Hobbs won this guy doesn't like it
reality can be tough Kevin wrote In
and Kevin's this one's is interesting I
bet you're like five seven one thirty
five pounds running your the f word for
a gay person liberal mouth like you're
intimidating or something
it's always the unathletic looking
Pencil Neck nerds like you who talk s
like you're intimidating why oh you are
the wrong you're
like you're intimidating you see the
name and face remember it you five seven
f word for a gay person haha that is
unacceptable Kevin I am five eight one
fifty please sir
please do not undersell Me by an inch
this is a guy where where uh clearly
he's lost the importance of inches that
you can tell
um yeah I mean obviously we know the
best criticism of someone's political
views is their height or their weight uh
very very nicely done all right let's
get into some more serious stuff Tom Tom
wrote in about alternatives to prison
for Trump
about a hypothetical Trump trial what
happens can you even really send Trump
to prison and Tom writes David I predict
that Trump will have to enter a plea
deal to avoid a jury trial after an
indictment is handed down he won't be
able to testify under oath of course and
some of the evidence against him is
certain to bring a conviction a lot of
the evidence Trump wouldn't want
disclosed in open court so here's what I
think will happen Trump will enter an
Alfred plea allowing him to plead guilty
without making specific admissions in
allowing this type of plea the
prosecution will need certain things
first they'll need for Trump to return
the missing documents he stole without
his at this action there should be no
deal then they should require him to
withdraw his candidacy and as a
condition never seek elected office
again which would prohibit him from
fundraising again lastly he'll be
required to serve in-house detention for
a period of time to be determined that
period of time will prohibit him from
Mass communicating fundraising and he'll
be similarly enjoined from most social
activities like most prisoners this will
set up this setup will allow the Secret
Service to continue to protect him while
serving his sentence at Mar-A-Lago it's
not going to be the perfect answer
writes Tom but the unusual circumstances
preclude Perfection and while I'd prefer
that Trump just go to trial be convicted
and sent to prison my sense is that it's
just not likely to happen feel free to
use this idea for the purpose of
discussing likely outcome scenarios Tom
that's I mean it's a very interesting uh
suggestion I've not checked with lawyers
about its viability but at the surface
level
it seems completely plausible I think it
is important uh as my hair does
something very very weird I think it is
important
um that we take it step by step the
first step is simply is there going to
be an indictment increasingly the
expectation is yes let's get to that
first step before we go further all
right let's now talk about in cells last
early last week I did a commentary about
incels and the the response was
overwhelming we heard from incels
we heard from anti-in cells we heard
from all sorts of people so let's go
through a few of the messages that I
received Daniel wrote in and said in
regards to how to help in cells I would
propose a more European approach to the
problem many countries in Europe have
legal brothels the sex industry does not
have nearly the negative stigma in these
countries as in the U.S I don't suggest
forcing anyone to work in prostitution
but I do suggest allowing people to make
the choice of working in a legalized
regulated and guarded industry
Daniel writes I am a former in cell I
have had the opportunity to work in
Germany and have used my per diem on
several occasions for recreation in the
reaper Bond brothels I found it was
possible to build rapport with some of
these women when I came back to the U.S
I continued to pay for female
companionship and was able to build
rapport with many of these women
gradually I was able to move to more
normal ways of meeting interacting and
building relationships with women I've
not been with a prostitute in over a
decade but I'm not embarrassed that I
found it to be therapeutic while I was
in need of help sexual desire is a human
natural human characteristic people who
are socially challenged should not be
criminalized for seeking to fill this
void even though it's a business
transaction feeling a bit of intimate
contact and not being made to feel like
a Frankenstein monster is a boost to the
self-esteem brothels should be readily
available to those in need writes Daniel
very interesting perspective that many
people who emailed shared here's an
another message from Scott about in
cells where he says David in your recent
segment regarding in cells you advocated
for increased mental health funding and
support for these individuals which I
think would definitely be at the base of
a multi-pronged effort that would be
needed to address this issue however
my feeling is that encouraging these
people to seek one another out so they
may find help or support is sort of what
got us in here in the first place years
ago before social media and online
forums you never heard about incels now
that people can access social media have
been able to locate other in cells I
feel they get stuck in Echo chambers
that help to normalize and rationalize
their feelings and that it's okay to
hate women or men or whoever it is they
feel rejected by that it's okay to have
thoughts about committing violence
against perceived enemies it reminds me
very much of the echo Chambers many
right wing extremists get caught up in
that normalize and encourage violence
all this to say I feel like the approach
within cells should be a little more
like deprogramming people lured into
Cults and discouraging use of social
media to help with this problem
I mean what better way for people to
become sexually active than to get off
their devices and actually interact in
the flesh with others in the real world
so here's an idea that says not more
online stuff that doesn't seem good Nick
wrote in and also is thinking legal
prostitution would help saying David I
watched your segment I believe federally
legalizing prostitution would really
help this issue the reality is that not
everyone is going to be able to find a
partner giving those people the option
to pay for sex would really benefit
their mental health by giving them an
outlet for their sexual frustration it's
basically just providing a service to
solve a problem just like anything else
if not for stigma surrounding
prostitution in America I believe in
cells would almost cease to exist what
are your thoughts some certainly would
I think for many of them the anxiety of
even going to a sex worker would prevent
them from doing it uh I don't know I I
think there's something to this idea but
I think we need to explore it
um probably a little more more deeply uh
Rich wrote in and says thank you from an
incel David sir I commend and thank you
for your segment on incels I am an incel
I joined an emotional support group on
Facebook after some time I expressed my
loneliness and frustration and desire to
improve my experience with dating I got
absolutely torn apart by people accusing
me of all kinds of nasty things not one
person commiserated or responded with
empathy for example women don't owe you
sex no kidding I'm not saying they
should fall at my feet I'm saying I want
to improve myself so that I can have
some success with dating it was
especially frustrating because it was an
emotional support group
I tried bringing attention to this
failure for a couple of days until the
moderators got involved accusing me of
the very same things and shaving me I
gave up I left I resent them to this day
and the one thing I wanted to say to
them is something like this is exactly
the kind of response that causes people
like me to get radicalized I'm not
radicalized says rich I never will be
but I am still very much an incel and
the stigma surrounding this is lonely
and alienating I just straight up don't
know what to do about it all I can say
is I love to see people like you cover
this with compassion and understanding
and with differentiation between the
radicalized in cells and the regular
everyday Schmucks like me much love says
rich
man this is this is a complicated issue
that is for sure and I really really
really appreciate all of the feedback
about that segment we're going to cover
it again lastly Tweeter wrote in and
said if Trump and his henchmen don't get
put away
the world will think we are weak people
got hurt and the capital those charges
should count too
this is an argument which is if there
are no consequences to any of the
organizers of the riots
what does it say about the people
thinking about planning something
similar I think that's a fair question
to ask info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today remember don't
allow yourself to be blocked from the
bonus show get the bonus show by signing
up at joinpakman.com and remember to
subscribe to the YouTube channel there's
this
um uh sort of bystander effect where
people watch our videos and they go oh
he's got 1.5 million subscribers I'm
sure other people will subscribe to get
them to 2 million no no no no
you can be that person don't fall prey
to the bystander effects subscribe make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
youtube.com the davidpackman show and
we'll be at 2 million before you know it
see you on the bonus track